avec nous la nouvelle présidente de
l'assemblée nationale il ya le brunch iv
bonsoir bonsoir vous venez d'être élu
nouvelle présidente de l'assemblée
nationale avec 242 voix au second tour
votre réaction et qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous c'est beaucoup
d'émotion et un grand honneur que m'ont
fait aujourd'hui les parlementaires en
médisant président de l'assemblée
nationale j'ai le sentiment des
sentiments mêlés un sentiment de joie
forcément parce que c'est un grand
moment pour une élue d'être élu par ses
pairs pour exercer des responsabilités
c'est un moment important dans notre
histoire puisque je suis la première
femme de l'histoire de la république à
être élue présidente de l'assemblée
nationale et puis c'est un moment
important parce que notre assemblée n'a
jamais été aussi diverses il va falloir
faire en sorte que tout le monde se
parle que tout le monde puisse exercer
son mandat pleinement et donc il y à un
immense défi qui est posé aujourd'hui
alors justement première femme à occuper
cette fonction vous avez parlé de votre
maman vous avez parlé aussi de catherine
tasca une autre yvelinoise qui a été la
première présidente de la commission des
lois une fonction vous avez occupé aussi
c'est important de rendre hommage à ces
femmes là c'est important parce que on
est toujours le produit d'une histoire
on n'est pas des électrons libres ou des
éléments isolés donc on s'inscrit dans
un combat pour l'égalité donc là c'est
beaucoup de femmes et c'est catherine
tasca parce que elle a porté les lois
sur la parité qui font qu'aujourd'hui
les femmes sont entrés pleinement dans
les conseils municipaux dans les
conseils départementaux dans les régions
et donc c'est un acte fondateur pour
nous les femmes politiques et puis ma
mère parce que c'est toujours important
de savoir d'où l'on vient sa famille est
et nos parents nous on nous donne des
leçons de vie et ma mère m'a
effectivement appris à ne jamais me
résigner et a toujours emprunter le
chemin qui était le mien est pas celui
que les autres choisissait pour moi et
je pense que ça c'est un message
important que l'on peut adresser aux
français alors vous avez parlé d'une
assemblée divisée qu'elle présidente
vous allez être du coup une présidente
qui permet à chacun d'exister dans cet
hémicycle et de remplir la mission que
lui yahoo est lui a confié les français
donc une présidente qui laisse faire le
débat et qui fait en sorte que le débat
soit respectueux et permettent d'avancer
vers du conte premier des consensus
parce que c'est ce que les français
attendent de nous j'ai l'impression que
les français sont contents de
l'assemblée nationale qui l'ont élu à
nous de montrer digne maintenant de leur
vote deux dernières questions d'abord
revenir sur cette cérémonie du tromperie
au scope vous avez été désigné député de
l'année par ce magazine yves thréard
avait dit vous êtes pub menace je
reviens là dessus cette pugnacité vous
l'avez toujours et on l'a vu aujourd'hui
en fait mais oui en fait c'est vous
savez c'est ce qui ce qui me caractérise
mais parce que c'est c'est important de
en fait rien n'a rien et à qui personne
ne vous donne
les choses dans la vie il faut aller les
chercher il faut étudier il faut se
construire il faut aussi construire avec
les autres et c'est ce qui je crois
aussi a été saluée aujourd'hui
l'esprit de consensus dont j'ai toujours
fait preuve mais ça ne ça ne tombe pas
du ciel un dernier mot les yvelines au
coeur du pouvoir législatif une
présidente yvelinoise de l'assemblée
nationale est un président du sénat qui
était vinoy gérard larcher on dit
souvent que les yvelines c'est la petite
france parce qu'il y à tous dans les
yvelines et donc voilà c'est maintenant
le coeur des institutions qui
représentait dans les yvelines mais vous
savez une fois qu'on est président et du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale on est
vraiment on doit être présent sur tous
les territoires merci à elle brode cube
est donc la nouvelle présidente de
l'assemblée nationale première femme à
occuper ce poste merci merci à vous